un 'mea culpa' del líder de la iglesia
católica el papá francisco reconoció
errores en la evangelización y admitió
que en ocasiones la iglesia ha intentado
imponer su visión ignorando otras
culturas e incluso apelando a la
violencia y a la guerra algo que para él
no representa la visión cristiana de la
vida
son tantas las tentaciones de borghi son
muchas las tentaciones de querer imponer
el propio modelo de vida como si fuera
el más evolucionado y el más atractivo
cuantos errores se han realizado en la
historia de la evangelización queriendo
imponer un solo modelo cultural o leño
impone un solo modelo cultural encuestó
modo 7 de esta manera se ha privado a la
iglesia de la riqueza de muchas
expresiones locales que llevan consigo
la tradición cultural de poblaciones
enteras y entre producto por acción las
declaraciones del papa llegan un día
después del 12 de octubre jornada
marcada por las manifestaciones de
pueblos originarios que califican de
genocidio del accionar de los españoles
desde la llegada de cristóbal colón a
américa y rechazan las imposiciones que
trajo el catolicismo al continente un
repudio al que se sumó el presidente de
venezuela nicolás maduro por eso
nosotros nos sumamos
a las voces
que en américa se han levantado
para exigir al rey de españa que
rectifique su posición que reflexione y
que le pida perdón a américa por el
genocidio de 300 años contra los pueblos
originarios
el llamado de maduro se suma al del
mandatario mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador quien había exigido a la
monarquía española y a la iglesia que se
disculpen una demandada que el papá
francisco respondió con una carta en
septiembre con motivo de la
independencia de mexico en la que
defendió la necesidad de reconocer los
errores cometidos en el pasado